[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in albert breer senior nfl
reporter
what's uh that backdrop what's what's in
that door what's behind that door in
that floor right well the door i don't
know
maybe it wasn't in the shop before
you've seen the ohio state stuff i've
got the double
black diamond back there you've seen the
door i i've you've seen the rest of it
i'm not sure if you've seen the door
yeah i just wanted nothing behind the
door i actually locked it so my kids
can't come in first
all right give me the trades that should
happen
tomorrow yeah i mean i i think really
you're looking at some teams that you
wouldn't typically see as sellers out
there and so
um you know the patriots i think would
be a team to watch they've informed
other teams that
you know almost they're willing to
listen on almost anyone on their roster
um the eagles and vikings are two more
now i don't know if philly's approach
changes because they won last night and
they're in first place now but
um the eagles have sort of let other
teams know that they're willing to
listen on some of their veteran players
they've got cap issues coming
down the road um in 2021 with the cap
going down next year
the vikings are the other one that are
sort of interesting now again they're
another team that played well yesterday
but um you know i think they've sort of
kind of come to the realization that
this is it for their core
you know the guys like harrison smith
and kyle rudolph and eric kendricks and
anthony barr like they've sort of
reached the end with that group
and so they're sort of looking to turn
the page now too where
you know you could see certain players
like rudolph himself become available so
i think that the interesting thing about
this year's trade deadline is you have
some teams that have typically been
contenders that have
typically been buyers at this time of
year now
sort of kind of dipping their toe in the
water on being sellers
the trades that will happen
i i don't i mean right now dan like what
i've heard over the last couple of days
the prices
are are too high um and that teams are
wanting too much now
you know typically the way this happens
is over the last 24 hours you'll see
prices come down
a little bit um you know the patriots
have toyed with the idea of trading
stephon gilmore i don't know if they'll
be able to get
value but that's a big name for you um
out there
i think kyle rudolph could wind up
getting moved the jets are open for
business
you could see one of their tackles you
know maybe somebody like george fan
because there's such an offensive line
shortage across the league get moved
uh i don't know there's going to be a
ton of activity and i usually feel that
way like a lot of names get bandied
about
um and you don't normally see a ton of
activity
so you know i think what you're going to
see tomorrow is probably a bunch of
teams trying to drop salary ahead of
2021
and ask and the asking price right now
is a little high
to get those guys in the move we'll see
if it comes down has washington made
dwayne haskins available
i mean he's been available yeah i like i
don't know if they can get for him right
now i mean i think this is more kind of
checking out to see if he has value
uh he's really not in a good way
right now um in that place and you know
i think that there's
there's just a lot he has to fix and not
just from a playing standpoint
um you know i don't think they were real
happy with the way he carried himself
after he got benched
and so you know i i think that that's
part of the equation here is
uh you know how he's going to be
professionally and maybe putting him on
the block sort of sends a message to him
that
you're not untouchable here and that um
we can move you
and so you know washington's going to
look at a bunch of their veterans you
know guys like ryan kerrigan and ryan
anderson
are also available and dwayne haskins
name has come up
um you know again i just don't know that
you're gonna be able to get much value
for a guy
who's on a first round contract and
hasn't played very well
isn't this the owner's fingerprints on
this draft pick
yeah yeah i mean there's no question
about that you know i
i what i heard leading up to that draft
was actually that jay gruden like daniel
jones who obviously wasn't available to
them so it became a moot point
but that you know some of the coaches
like daniel jones a little bit more than
haskins and
i'm sure you know the story about how
about daniel snyder's son having gone to
high school at the bullet school
in in maryland with dwayne haskins so
there was that feel there that
um you know that that bruce allen and
dan snyder were really behind the dwayne
haskins pick because he's local
and it sounds silly it's amazing that
this could happen like the biggest
investment that you could possibly make
right dan
is in a first round quarterback and
you're making it based on the fact that
the kid grew up near the stadium but
that was the story that was circulating
at the time speaking of washington john
bostic
gets fined only 12 000 on his hit on
andy dalton like
where's the deterrent 12 grand yeah if
i'm a defensive player
i'll pay 12 grand to get a star
quarterback out of a game not saying
andy dalton's his star quarterback but
what's the deterrent well you know i
think the way they looked at that there
are a couple of things there like i
think number one
it was in the context of a play now was
it dirty i think so but
it was within the context of a play so
it's a little different than like the
javon wims situation from yesterday
number two if you look at it i mean i i
think in some of these cases
there is sympathy for when the
quarterback slides a little late
and a defensive player has his momentum
going
and so absolutely that was an ugly
looking hit to me it felt like it was
dirty
but if you really watch it i think you
can make the case that
by the time andy had kind of gone into
his slide
plastic's momentum was going forward and
so
i think in some of these situations when
the when it's within the context of the
play like if it's not extracurricular
and it's actually within like the
context of the football itself
the league can you know i think the
league acts with a little more sympathy
towards the defensive player and
i think that's what this was as much as
anything else i don't think it was
that the fallout the result of the hit
like the action itself i think more
than anything else it was sort of like
looking at it and slowing it down and
saying
that slide was a little late so we're
gonna give a guy break here
follow me on this it's never too soon to
talk about next year but
belichick loves jimmy garoppolo right
yeah yeah that's fair to say okay so
what
do you think would prevent belichick
from calling
kyle shanahan and john lynch and saying
what do you want for garoppolo
uh nothing i i don't think there's i
mean if they if they decide they're
gonna move on from cam newton i would
think jimmy garoppolo would be near the
top of the list
um you know they they offered jimmy
garoppolo a contract extension i don't
know how much that's been out there but
um you know over the summer of 2017 i
think it was that he got traded that
fall
right over the summer of 2017 they
offered him sort of a band-aid contract
you know
the sort of contract that like the
saints gave taysom hill or
uh you know back in the day the eagles
gave kevin cobb where it was sort of a
short-term contract to get you to the
next one
um so they liked him enough to try to
extend him and try to keep both him and
tom brady on the roster in 2017.
um you know and and and really part of
the whole deal dan was that
you know i mean it was sort of
communicated to bill not that you have
to trade jimmy but
that trading tom was going to be a tough
sell with ownership and so
it was a complicated situation at the
time i think bill's affection for jimmy
is there there's the personal connection
of course
and i think like something like that
would really come down to whether or not
the niners have a better option
like i don't think this is going to be
the niners looking to get out from
underneath jimmy garoppolo and we can go
through the whole thing that happened
last off-season again if you want
i think more than anything else like
this would be about the niners
somehow having a better option whether
it's kirk cousins or they're drafting in
the top 10 and it's trey lance from
north dakota state or something like
that
like the availability of jimmy garoppolo
i don't think is going to come down to
jimmy garoppolo himself as much as it's
going to come down
to what other options the niners have
out there and i brought up kirk cousins
reuniting with kyle shanahan matt ryan
reuniting with kyle shanahan like it
feels like if you said matt ryan was on
the 49ers and they're healthy
i would make them the nfc you know super
bowl favorites
yeah i mean i i don't disagree with you
and really i think with matt ryan you
would be doing the same thing that
you're doing with jimmy garoppolo right
which
it's like you know you have jimmy
garoppolo for now and i think i've made
i may have made this analogy with you
before
but it's sort of like alex smith in
kansas city right
like andy traded for alex smith and he
liked alex smith and they won a lot of
games with alex smith
but really what alex smith was doing for
you was buying you time until you ran
into somebody
you really loved and you were willing to
go all in on and that was patrick
mahomes
and so i think you know the same way
jimmy garoppolo is that guy for kyle
shanahan right now
i think matt ryan could absolutely be
that guy as well he's not that old
it's 33 i think he's 34 35 years old
right now i'd have to look that up but
um yeah i mean i don't disagree with you
i think matt ryan could be an upgrade
over jimmy garoppolo and there's
obviously a comfort level there between
the two
i think we just have to wait to see
who's running the falcons like until we
know who's running the falcons
and who's going to be making these
decisions in january it's really hard to
tell how realistic it is
sam darnold's days with the jets
numbered
they depend on where the jets are
picking i would say if
the jets have the number one overall
pick sam darnold gets traded
um because trevor lawrence is a
generational prospect
like a once in a decade prospect in the
vein of andrew luck peyton manning john
but will you find out before like you
have to make sure you know trevor
lawrence
is going to go into the draft before you
do anything
right well yeah and that'll be i mean
the deadline i believe is middle of
january okay
so you'll know i mean and trevor
lawrence could leverage that i'm not
saying he will
but he could leverage that like he could
say like i don't want to play for the
jets so i'm not they're
going to declare until you commit to
trading the pick like something wild
like that like
and i don't know i don't know what's in
trevor lawrence's head it doesn't seem
like it'd be of his nature to do that
but if he really looked at it and said i
i like i don't want to play there
he would have some leverage to do that
because he could you know say
if you don't deal a pick i'm going back
to school so you know
this thing could get a little
complicated i don't think it necessarily
will but
um yeah i mean i think trevor lawrence i
think there are very few teams
that would trade that pick like i think
you are going based realistically on who
has who at quarterback
and where those teams are in the
standings i think whoever
i think you're going to have to be the
worst team in the league to get trevor
lawrence
and so i think if trevor lawrence
becomes available to the jets it's
academic you trade sam darnold
i think if you're picking second or
third that's something else and then
it's like
all right now we have to really look at
this and compare like sam darnold
against st
justin fields i'm just wondering about
what's going on in cleveland with baker
mayfield
uh it feels like the the time frame is
sped up now with these quarterbacks
they want to find out that's why miami's
you know putting tua in
because you're gonna have four draft
picks in the first two rounds and you're
gonna have the texans draft pick so
you wanna know is to our guy do the
browns know if baker mayfield is their
guy
i don't think so yet um and i think one
thing that really hurts baker is
you know the investment level of people
who are going to be making those
decisions
the investment level in baker mayfield
of the general manager
andrew berry and the head coach kevin
stefanski is very low
um barry was there when they drafted
mayfield but he wasn't really a part of
that part of the process that was really
john dorsey
and kevin stefanski wasn't around at all
and so you know you have both those guys
who are evaluating a player that they
didn't pick
that they have no investment to that
their job security isn't tied to
um you know and you know i think the
other piece of this
is um you know you look at where they
are contractually and this is the way it
works this is why that
timetable gets kind of sped up dan is
after the third year
you've got to make a decision on the
fifth year option and in the new cba
that fifth year option is fully
guaranteed and so one way or another
going into that fourth year you've got
to declare where you're at on that
quarterback
like if you remember last year the bears
said all and all these nice things about
miss trubisky
then they declined his fifth year option
and we all knew where they stood right
like so
like this is the time like after three
years based on the way these contracts
work
this is one you have to declare that
goes for
this year at least that goes for baker
mayfield and cleveland it goes for sam
darnold with the jets
it goes for josh allen and buffalo and
of course it goes for lamar
lamar jackson in baltimore too which
will be a little bit of an easier
decision i would think
yeah it's really interesting uh you know
i keep seeing like sam darnold with the
steelers
you know the eventual successor to ben
or you know
what chicago do the chicago trade for
somebody
it just like is matthew stafford going
to be in detroit uh you're gonna have a
new coaching regime probably brought in
there it just feels like there's
there's four or five quarterbacks and
not even including the draft
that's the thing though is like i i
think part of this dan is that we're in
this golden age for quarterbacks if you
look
back at like the last i think it's like
the last five years
the number was 17 quarterbacks have
like been drafted in the top you know in
in in the first round and of those 17
it's something like 11 you could say
like legitimately have made it
already and are like entrenched as like
okay like this is our long-term starter
so i think there's a combination of
players really working out on that end
right and then you have a bunch of older
guys who are hanging out hanging around
longer than we've ever seen before guys
like brady and brees
and i think what it's led to is there's
almost more supply than there is demand
across the nfl now which is why we are
in that situation last year where
you had philip rivers make it to the
market tom brady make it to the market
you had like a bunch of guys who
probably would have gotten real money in
years past like jameis winston and cam
newton
sitting on the market available for a
while so you know it's just an
interesting
situation at the position in general and
somebody like sam darnold could wind up
being really
you know attractive i mean you look back
at some of the teams that really liked
him
coming out in 2018 i'll give you another
one the broncos loved him the broncos
would have taken him fifth overall
if you're the broncos right now based on
what you've seen from drew lock and he
looked pretty good yesterday
like that's sort of a decision you'd
have to make right like if he came
available
and you're john l way it's like yeah we
really like drew locke but
you know maybe sam darnold is behind
door number two and that would make some
sense for us so
i think like you know that game of
musical chairs we had a quarterback last
year i don't think it'll be just the
same
because obviously last year brady was a
free agent but i think you could see
some interesting movement with some of
these younger guys
great to catch up with you as always we
appreciate your time albert thank you
awesome thanks dan you can now unlock
the door whatever is behind you
you can now unlock the door
oh yeah i even knew you were still
talking yes
my kids actually my kids actually snuck
in twice during quarantine so i wanted
to spare you guys the third time
all right thank you amber that's always
breer a senior nfl reporter uh works for
the mmqb
and nbc sports boston